let me tell you what you are
missing Dr
Jones while you were playing your
pointless
game I was playing
you you're wondering if maybe you should
have built yourself a life of
meaning instead of ending up
here de and forgotten in the sense of
[Music]
Africa
myths
history just different ways to interpret
the past
thousands of years of Humanity's
thoughts and
beliefs scattered and
buried just
waiting to be
found you can't just run away from your
problems
Indiana watch me
throughout
history mankind has built SES of great
spiritual
significance if you were to draw a line
through these ancient sites around the
globe you get a perfectly aligned
Circle
[Music]
I've had run-ins with these guys
before trust
me it ain't a walk in the park okay then
let's see if you can keep up what do you
mean if I can keep
[Music]
up
patron of the Fallen
Angels protector of
the
chulman the great
[Music]
circle you have any idea how old that
was
I